la gloire tti qu'encore très populaire
tu étais très très populaire et mine de
rien du jour au lendemain c'est vrai
qu'on ne voit plus trop à la télévision
oui c'est comme il y en avait patrick
savatier voilà et qu'est ce qui s'est
passé en fait une parenthèse lorientaise
pour la vie est une parenthèse pour
porter quoi qui a décidé d'arrêter pour
le coup ou je fais dire il était temps
que j'arrête
pourquoi il est pour des raisons
personnelles que tu connais d'ailleurs
ne va pas les évoquer ici parce que vous
avez vous d'autres choses à m'occuper
quelqu'un m'occuper à maman manière
voilà et que et que j'ai fait cette
parenthèse parce qu'elle m'a pris un
jour la main j'avais deux ans et demi
n'était pas question que je lui lâche
des places adoptée à deux ans et demi
est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui et depuis quelques mois tout
va bien fait un come back
je reviens à la vie oui ça nous
travaillerons pour une scène pour un
projet qui va émerger très bientôt
autour de l'art contemporain et la
télévision et je suis absolument ravi de
diriger ses programmes magloire la télé
tu manques ou pas oui est ce que tu as
des bons souvenirs qu'elle est plus gros
souvenirs n'y a pas trop trop trop il ya
trop de choses la télé oui c'est que
c'est une drogue dure de dire et la
télévision a envie de revenir à fond
mais ce que je fais aujourd'hui c'est de
la télévision faire des programmes c'est
imaginez pas que le ferait un jour je le
fais avec plaisir je viendrai vous en
reparler prochainement
mais effectivement de la télé ou de la
télé qui a du sens aussi envie d'en
faire effectivement terre d'errance moi
même question posée à magloire ici
autour de la table beinheim non mais
c'est sas qu'il avait envie de travers
merci benhaim premièrement que sa santé
parce que tout le monde a beaucoup parlé
de ça deuxièmement il a été victime des
réseaux sociaux qui dit qu'il était mort
et je trouve ça absolument abjecte à
abjecte ont appris le même os et
révoltant donc un peu à voir sa réaction
avait commencé à magloire la santé ça va
très bien je me surveille on surveille
tout va bien kate est vraiment occident
mais ça y est on est on est apte de
nouveau et les réseaux sociaux c'est
vrai que je lance un signal assez
terrible mais aujourd'hui clichy c'est
vrai donc c'était plutôt difficile pour
la famille surtout à bien fermer
aujourd'hui 107 ont évoqué tout à
l'heure je peux assumer plus facilement
ce genre de problème